okay
listen i'm not i for people listening i
do not have
trump derangement syndrome i'm i don't i
see
i try to look for the good and the bad
in everybody
one thing perhaps it's irrational but
perhaps because i've been reading
history
i the one triggering thing for me
is the delaying of elections
i believe in elections and
[Music]
this is this is the part that you
probably disagree with
but i i you know i believe in the value
of people voting
and i just seen too many dictators that
the place where they finally
the big switch happens when you
question the legitimacy of elections
who's been questioning the legitimacy of
elections for the last three years
i've only heard donald trump do it last
like year but the last three years
you're saying
somebody else you don't think not my
president
illegitimate we're not gonna normalize
him as president russia hacked this
election
impeached you're not a real president
you don't think that's questioning
legitimacy of 2016.
no it's a good uh i haven't been paying
attention enough but
i i would i would imagine that argument
has been
that i haven't actually heard too many
people but i imagine that's been a
popular
oh very much yeah okay i
but nevertheless that's a part that
didn't uh
that's not a statement that gained power
enough to say
that um barack obama will keep being
president
or hillary clinton should be president
newsweek had that article how hillary
clinton could still be president
newsweek
no but she's not that's what i'm saying
my worry
isn't my worry isn't uh
saying that the election was
illegitimate and people whining
and mass scale and then the fox news or
cnn
reporting for years or books being
written for years my worry
is legitimately martial law
a person stays president so here's the
issue
like there's a there's a phase shift
that i have not i
i did a book on north korea i'm not
someone who thinks
dictatorship should be taken lightly i'm
not someone who thinks it can't happen
here
uh i i think a lot of times people are
desperate for dictatorship so i am with
you and i think this is something
if you're going to hand wave it away
everyone else hand waved it away
hitler's never going to be chancellor
he's a lunatic
he's a joke he's a joke that he they
couldn't find a publisher from mineconf
in english
because this is some guy from some
random minor party in germany spouting
nonsense who's going to read this crap
you know so i i completely agree with
you uh you don't think we're there
my point is donald trump this year
had every uh pathway open to him to
declare martial law
the cities were being burnt down he
could have very easily sent in the tanks
uh and people would have been applauding
him from his side he feels so good right
now but am i wrong though
no i what he did he tweeted out to mayor
wheeler of
portland he said call me
we will we will solve this in minutes
but you
have to call and he sat in his hands and
they said oh it's his fault
the city is burning down he's not doing
anything and he goes i'm not doing
anything until you ask me to do it so i
think that
is even if you think he's an aspiring
dictator
that is at least a sign that there is
some restraint
on his aspirations can i just
take that in as a beautiful um
like moment of hope so i'm i'm gonna
remember this
ted cruz beautiful ted i'm gonna
remember that i mean
uh i i i should say that perhaps i'm
irrationally this is the one moment
where i feel myself being a little
i i don't think it's irrational i think
there's an asymmetry
because it's kind of like okay either i
if i leave the house it's like russian
roulette
yeah maybe it's like a one and six shot
i'm pulling the trigger i'm killing
myself but
that's one in six that's not and and the
consequences are so dire
that a little paranoia would go a long
way there's something that you can't go
back
yeah it's an asymmetry yeah and the the
thing is
the thing that makes donald trump new
to me and again i'm a little naive in
these things
but he surprised
me in how many ways
he just didn't play by the rules yeah
and he's made me a little ant in this
ant colony
think like well do you have to play by
the rules at all
right like why are we having elections
why just say like it's coronavirus time
like it's
it's uh not healthy to have elections
like we shouldn't be
like i could if i put my dictator hat on
nancy pelosi said that joe biden
shouldn't debate
yeah uh did she yes she says
she shouldn't dignify trump with the
debate he's the president he could be
the worst president on earth evil
despicable monster
i'll i'll take that as an argument so
she's playing politics but she's
i don't think that's playing politics i
think when there's a certain point where
things get
when things get uh when you start
attacking institutions
for the the emergencies of the moment
and acting arbitrarily that is when
things
are the slippery slope yeah so you're
saying debates is one of the
institutions like that's one of the
traditions to have the debates
i think the debates are extremely
important uh and now i don't think that
someone's a good debater is going to
make a good president
i mean that's that's a big problem but
you're just saying this is attacking
just yet another
tradition yet another you know like how
if you're dating if you're married to
someone and someone throws out the word
divorce you can't unring that bell you
threw it out there
yeah i'm saying you don't throw things
out like that unless
you really are ready to go down this
road and i think that is
there's nothing in the constitution
about debates we've only had them since
but still i think they are extremely
important it's also a great chance for
joe biden to tell him to his face
you're full of crap here's what you did
here's what you did here's what you did
so fascinating that you're both
you acknowledge that and you you also
see the value of tearing down the entire
thing so you're both worried about no
debates
or at least in your voice in your tone
there's a great quote by chesterton
i'm not a fan of him at all but he says
before you tear down a fence make sure
you know why they put it up first
so i am for tearing it all down but
there's something called a controlled
demolition
like building seven um or there's
legendary
we knew we were in tel aviv um and
hashtag building seven we knew we were
intelligent
wow you're faster than me you're you're
operating in a different level
i need to upgrade my operating system i
told you windows 95.
yeah um building seven
if you're gonna uh it's like indiana
jones right if you're gonna tear
pull something away make sure you have
something in place first as opposed to
just breaking it and then just
especially in politics it because it
escalates and when things escalate
without any kind of
response it it can go in a very bad
that's when napoleon comes in
you